ich habe ausnahmsweise mal keine
Jogginghose an können wir das mal
appreciatenxum so meine Damen und Herren
ich hoffe sie sitzen gut sie sind
angeschnallt denn jetzt gibt was ganz
verrücktes den advskalender von
juwelkerze ich sag euch wie es ist
juwelkerze kenne ich nur von der Sar
Harrison Kooperation mit juwelkerze ein
Paket bekommen von juwelkerze und das
Prinzip ist ganz einfach von juwelkerze
es sind
Kerzen
und das war's mit dem Video vielen Dank
bis nächsten Mal also juwelkerze sagt
eigentlich schon alles was es ist es
sind Kerzen mit Schmuck drin und da
könnt ihr euch vorstellen dass ich sehr
gespannt darauf bin was in so einem
juwelkerzen advventskalender drin ist
sind jetzt hier 24 Kerzen drin der
Kalender kostet 149 € und soll ein
Gewicht von 7300 g haben alter Schwede
das stimmt der ist wirklich sehr sehr
schwer es kann also sein dass hier
wirklich einfach nur 24 Kerzen drin sein
werden sagt niemanden ne ich ma mal
meine Hose auf deswegen drehe ich mit J
Hose tägliches Staunen mit Kerzen
Weihnachtsdekorationen Schmuck und viele
mehr das lassen wir uns doch nicht
zweimal sagen packen wir doch aus ich
muss danach jetzt auch mal ein paar
günstigere Adventskalender Auspacken ich
habe das Gefühl wir sind hier ein
bisschen ausgeartet mit den Preisen
1200 €
210 € dieser Kalender kostet 600 € 149 €
ist schon wieder viel aber ich meine
okay ist aber auch ein sehr schwerer
Kalender ne optisch gefällt er mir schon
mal sehr gut
love sun and moon und Sternzeichen
we erinnert mich vom Look an Paul
Valentine ach toll und bevor ich jetzt
hier noch zu oft juwelkerze sage dieses
Video ist nicht gesponsert und jetzt
alle dieses Video ist nicht gesponsert
ich habe ih mir selbst gekauft optisch
10 von ich stehe total auf diesen Look
ich habe mir sogar auch die Jungfrauen
Sternkonstellation auf mein Arm
tätowiert Weihnachtsdekoration Swarowski
kriegt Konkurrenz also jetzt mal
wirklich Paul in guckt mal wie stabil
der ist schaut mal dann nehme ich eins
raus und dann fällt nur das runter weil
hier eine Zwischenplatte ist Nummer eins
aber Moment mal hat er eigentlich einen
höheren Warenwert oder so nee wie
erfrischend so gucken wir mal
ne okay vielleicht glaubt ihr mir das
nicht aber ich habe die ganze Zeit
gedacht dass ich so ein einzelnen
Kerzenständer haben möchte weil ich bei
mir noch ganz viele lange Kerzen
gefunden habe und dann dachte ich ich
will ein so wo ich so einfach eine Kerze
ohne viel tamt ich finde es optisch
wunderschön jetzt sagt mir nicht also
hat ein bisschen so ein
glasarschenbecherweib stylisch schlicht
weihnachtlich super love
it verkaufen sie sowas dort nee aber
tolle Auswahl ich bin hyped ich sag's
euch wie es ist Nummer Z großes Paket
ich weiß nicht was der Begriff taper
candle bedeutet ich würde jetzt einfach
sagen lange Kerze spitzkerze der
Fachbegriff es ist eine gold
angespritzte Kerze cool die sieht geil
aus und sie macht Sinn toll und sogar
noch eine zweite Mensch Kerzen seit 2000
Jahren super dafür stehe ich mit meinem
Namen wie lange gibt's Kerzen die
Erfindung der Kerze selbst liegt
schätzungen zufolge mindestens
5000 Jahre zurück seit 5000 Jahren hat
sich dieses Prinzip bewrt Nummer D oh
wie
cool ich lieb's Adventskerzen für den
kleinsten Adventskranz der Welt macht
man sich da jeden Sonntag eine an die
gehen nur halt sehr kurz ne man muss
dann schnell sein ich weiß gar nicht wie
lange geht den so ein Teelicht drei bis
vier Stunden also dann darf man die
maximal eine Stunde anhaben damit sie
die ganze Zeit schafft passend zum
ersten der dritte ist nämlich der erste
Advent und dann hast du gleich Kerzen
nice in Türchen Nummer 4 befindet sich
uh ne dicke Kerze ich liebe einfach
Kerzen ich ich jetzt sage ich es ist
raus ich liebe Kerzen ich sehe dass eine
Kerze drin ist perfekt oh wie toll die
ausseht das ist eine Kerze im metallic
Look time to shine ich lebe schon lange
auf dieser Welt ne aber so eine tolle
Kerze habe ich noch nie gesehen das
einzige Manko aber dann wäre dieser
Kalender halt einfach auch unbezahlbar
dass das halt nicht so ein geiles
sojawachs oder sowas ist das ist halt so
dieses Wachs so glaube ich ja muss
es Nummer 5 wird hier eine Kerze drin
sein na das sehen wir jetzt was ist das
starb eine Badebombe ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt von so einem
kerzenadventskalender also was zum
Reinigen für die Haut haben ist ein
schönes Gimmick ist schön so aber ja das
ist so das erste tchen W ich sagen aber
es riecht gut aber sie sind sich dem
Look treu geblieben passt zusammen
diesen Kalender hat auf jeden Fall
jemand erstellt der ein gutes Auge hat
und jetzt gibt es Türchen Nummer 6 es
ist Nikolaus und wir gehen an unseren
Kalender und machen ihn und dann gibt es
Schmuck ein kleines Schmucksäckchen was
wird hier wohl drin sein auch eine
Metall Kette ach die ist ja süß schaut
mal die hat auch so ein Sternbild ein
sternkonstellations
sternstraßen
Sterne heute kann ich sie echt nicht
tragen aber sieht sie aus gell e und für
150 € ja da drücke ich noch mal ein Auge
zu wenn es halt nur Metall ist nicht so
wie bei
Swarowski eine sehr schöne Kette ich
hätte jetzt aber gedacht die sind doch
in den Kerzen drin als nächstes haben
wir die Nummer 7
ja spread the Sparkle oh
Duft ich kann euch absolut nicht
sagen wonach die riecht ja ich will
wegen grün will ich sagen Tannenbaum
aber das ist bisschen nicht wahr ein
angenehmer Duft also ich kann sehr viel
daran riechen und es ist immer noch
angenehm ja und passt natürlich optisch
perfekt zu dieser kleinen Familie hier
drüben und ich haben vor zwei Wochen
ungefähr unser Wohnzimmer einmal so ein
bisschen gemütlicher gemacht wir haben
so zwei kleine Lampen dazu gekauft die
wir in die Ecken gestellt haben und wir
haben uns Kerzen gekauft die wir so ein
bisschen verteilt haben das macht so
einen Unterschied jetzt gerade zu der
Jahreszeit wo es so schnell dunkel wird
gibt's ein wirklich so ein cozy Gefühl
also Kerzen mein Pro Tip an dieser
Stelle frage ich mich ob was ich für
scheiß aber ist irgendwie komisch die
Kamera so sch ich fühle mich jetzt viel
mehr als ob ich moderieren müsste vorher
stand sie halt so voll nah an der Seite
und dann konnte ich halt einfach so die
Seite reinlabern so und jetzt fühle ich
mich so als ob ich ein bisschen mehr
abliefern muss wisst ihr wer auch noch
abliefern muss ihr bitte Abonniert mal
diesen Kanal ich bin bei 932 000
Abonnenten ihr meine Videos gerne schaut
abonniert mich einfach nur für eine
kurze Zeit dass ich einmal die eine
Million Abonnenten erreiche und dann
könnt ihr mich wieder abonnieren ich
will nur diesen play bututton haben die
man bekommt bitte gönnt einer Schwester
ihren play bututton Nummer a sind wir
hier bei Game of Thrones oder
was ich habe absolut keine Ahnung was
das ist wist ihr was das ist ich hte
jetzt gedacht dass man das vielleicht so
auf eine Kerze drauf machen muss oder
drunter oder so aber so ist es nicht
gedacht niemals es gibt viele Dinge die
ihr mit diesem random Teil machen könnt
wow ja es sieht ganz nett aus ich habe
aber keine Ahnung was das sein soll es
gibt auch keine Erklärung und also auch
kein Heft dazu das muss man sich dann am
Ende selbst zusammenreimen so jetzt
kommt Türchen Nummer 9 und Türchen
Nummer 9 ist das beste Türchen we meine
Lieblingszahl
ist das ein dickes Paket sieht do so
hübsch aus guckt mal ein tolles Paket
ich lieb
es
jawoh genau das was ich brauche in
meinem Leben beautiful gorgeous
amazing fantastic also ich muss sagen
der Kalender ließ jetzt nicht also
dunkelgrün für mich ze von ze wenn ich
jetzt z.B Silber pinkes Wohnzimmer hab
dann ist das natürlich ein bisschen
schwierig mit grün und gold macht man zu
Weihnachten jetzt schon mal nichts
falsch außer man mag das nicht ne dann
hat man ins Klo gegriffen weil der
Kalender sieht jetzt nicht nach grün und
gold aus sondern eigentlich nach Blau
und Gold Nummer 10
oh cute wow love it amazing kann man
immer gebrauchen ist schön weihnachtlich
toll aus stellt man irgendwo hin stellt
sich Gott verdamte K dazu und BAM und
dann stell noch den Tannenbaum daneben
hast du das
weihnachtlich Nummer 11 sieht aus als ob
ich eine Apple watch bekommen würde
Apple watch in Apple watchu sagin oh was
passiert hier
produktwiederholungkerze man hat die
Kerzen ja schon längst abgebrannt weil
man sich das abends immer so schön
gemütlich macht und jetzt bekommt man
Nachschub kaputt sie ist gebrochen
ne ist an der Stelle hier gebrochen das
macht nichts aus also wenn es
runterbrennt dann brennt halt immer noch
gut trotzdem sie ist gebrochen und jetzt
sind wir im dunkelblau angekommen ja das
ist optisch okay zusammen ich habe doch
eben gerade noch von dunkelblau
gesprochen beten wir jetzt kommt alles
in dunkelblau wenn sich alles noch mal
in dunkelblau wiederhol h dann F ich
schade Türchen Nummer 12 Halbzeit
manchmal ja ich wusste es doch es ist
aber nicht das Gleiche Blau das ist ein
sehr intensives Blau seht ihr das kommt
in der Kamera glaube ich nicht so ganz
rüber aber ja das ist so ein richtiges
blau blau blau wie findet ihr das
optisch zusammen schreibt mal eure
Bewertung in die Kommentare ja bei Grün
habe ich mich tierisch gefreut bei blau
ist jetzt so ein bisschen ja das ist
jetzt genau das eingetreten mein ja es
ist immer noch okay zusammen aber ja
doch ich kann mich gerade noch nicht
ganz entscheiden wie ich das Nummer
13 Wiederholung finde ich aber gut mein
erster Gedanke eben war nämlich ich
hätte gerne ein zweites davon weil ich
finde eins ist mir zu wenig dann dachte
ich ich will ein so eins wo ich so
einfach eine Kerze gerade für so eine
Tischdekoration da passen schon wenn es
so zwei nebeninander sind tja jetzt darf
sich nicht alles wiederholen also das
war ja gut ne aber in 14 wiederholt es
sich jetzt nicht noch mal es wiederholt
sich noch eine Duftkerze die relativ
gleich riecht wie die andere
nee gar nicht die riecht nach frisch
gewaschener Wäsche haben die denn hier
für so ein Abenteuer mit dem blau
gemacht ich meine weiß ja weiß grün gold
jetzt ist es spannend was da noch so
passiert Nummer 15 wird es sich
wiederholen da kommt sehr viel Glitzer
raus sieht mir doch schon wieder nach
Teelichtern aus versteht mich nicht
falsch silberne Glitzer Teelichter sind
ja nicht schlecht aber wir sind bei Gold
und grün weiß ich nicht diger passt
nicht nicht so gut aber sind schön aber
passt nicht 16 in Nummer 16 haben wir
einen candle holder das hätten wir auch
für dieses Teil gebraucht eine
Erklärung das sieht ja cool aus das Teil
steckt man hier rein das steckt man da
rein nee sag mir bitte nicht ist so rum
oh ich glaube das wirurd falsch
rumgemacht das macht doch gar keinen
Sinn ach da ist noch eine Folie drauf oh
ich bin so deppert okay ich habe schon
gedacht das sieht so hässlich aus dieses
weiße das stand aber nicht in der
Anleitung oh man muss die noch so
abziehen satisfy
so sieht's doch richtig
aus das finde ich hübsch Leute das dreht
sich ja jetzt ist ein kerzentopper aber
ich habe keine Kerze ich finde das so
schön Nummer 17 ist sehr klein und sehr
leicht Adventssonntag ne das passende
Armband für die Kette ich bin kein
armbandträger ich sag euch wie es ist da
kann ich mich auch nicht für begeistern
auch für so Sets also ich trage nicht
gerne passenden Schmuck ich weiß aber
dass andere das gerne machen deswegen ja
und meine Dame Herr in der Nummer 18
befindet sich natürlich ach ja klar oh
die riecht ein bisschen düster Magic
Darling ja ist okay eine schwarze Kerze
nicht eher so Halloween dann mach doch
lieber blau obwohl das wüns ich mir
lieber nicht zu laut die blaue Kerze
kommt wahrscheinlich auch noch fast so
gut wie die Nummer 9 die Nummer
19 ein zweites Haus das kleine Dörfchen
hier wird immer voller bisschen random
auch ne aber ja ja da macht man halt
Teelicht da rein das ist halt ein
teelichthaus eigentlich gar nicht random
es ist ein kerzenadventskalender und
damit sind wir schon bei unserem 20ern
angekommen der Adventskalender sieht
mittlerweile so aus wie die
supermarktreale zur coronazeit das heißt
wir sind fast durch und in der 20
bekommen wir eine schwarze Kerze nicht
mal die Kamera möchte mehr komm jetzt
zeig die schwarze Kerze jetzt zeig doch
die schwarze Kerze hier bin
ich na ja ihr habt s gesehen eine Kombi
die muss man sich erst trauen ne
21 ja GI noch den Tannenbaum in Klein
den kerzentannenbaum das Weihnachtsdorf
wird immer größer und voller ja ja ich
fand den das erste Mal gut jetzt gibt's
den halt noch mal in kleiner
22 da ist sie da ist sie meine Damen und
Herren so genau wie wir sie erwartet
haben uh dieser Kerze können wir zur
Spurensicherung gehen seht ihr den
Fingerabdruck okay ich muss aber noch
mal eine Sache zurücknehmen also der
Kalender hat von den Farben genau das
wie Sie die Verpackung es vermuten hat
lassen außer die silbernen Teelichter
Nummer 23 der letzte Tag vor Weihnachten
ja ja okay die braucht man ist jetzt
natürlich ein bisschen spät jetzt haben
wir schon alle Kerz wir hab schon die
meisten angemacht aber Streichhölzer
lange Streichhölzer sind auch cute damit
fühlt man sich cool advent
Advent ein Lichtlein brennt mich gar
nicht entschieden welche Kerze ich
anmachen möchte wir müssen keine Kerze
anmachen es geht immer wieder an jetzt
geht es aus guck mal wie kurz sie nur
gebrannt hat das kleine Stück ich meine
gut man kann dann da
mit Statement juwelkerze Statement
kommen wir zum letzten tüchchen
wow das ist schwer 24 habe das Gefühl 4
Kil sind alleine schon hier drin es ist
Weihnachten wir gehen zu unserem
juwelkerzen Adventskalender und was
bekommen wir natürlich boah die riecht
nach Marshmallow eine
og juwelkerze wunderschöner Look ja
Magic KS dieses Sternbilder konst
finde ich
wunderschön riecht sie orange
Marshmallow könen wir damit anfangen
orange Marshmallow na hier muss doch
jetzt
aber der Strau passen das sieht so cool
es sieht wirklich cool aus okay eine
letzte Geschichte muss ich noch erzählen
früher in der Grundschule durfte immer
einer die Kerzen anmachen und das wurde
dann so ausgewählt dafür musste man dann
die Streichhölzer nehmen und die Kerze
anmachen und ich habe mich nie
freiwillig gemeldet weil ich so Schiss
davor hatte das zu machen kinderind so
dumm sag mal bewegt sich das durch die
Hitze oder so automatisch das ist das
schönste was ich hier gesehen habe ja
liebe Kinder das war's mit diesem Video
ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen ich hoffe
ihr hattet auch Spaß beim Zuschauen ich
fand den Kalender richtig richtig toll
ich mag alles und ich weiß dass alles
ganz genauso in meiner Wohnung stehen
wird das einzige Manko ist diese blauen
Kerzen aber hier in dieser Kombination
mit den finde ich das toll also da
passen die Farben zu auch diese schwarze
Kerze aber diese blaue glitzerkerze mit
der komme ich noch nicht ganz klar ich
finde 149 € sind hier gut investiert ich
mag wirklich alle Produkte die Ketten
die Teelichter die Teelicht die
Kerzenhalter die kleinen Häuschen diese
Kerzen außer die blaue da mit der blauen
haben sie sich keinen Gefallen getan
obwohl das hier in der Kombination mit
dem Blau gut aussieht juwelkerze bitte
sag mal ganz kurz was das sein soll ach
das ist bestimmt auch zum ja jetzt jetzt
checke ich das hört auch so für eine
Kerze oben drauf aber sorry D damit kann
nichts
mithalten das dreht sich einfach weiter
ne ich mag den Kalender ich sag's euch
wie es ist ich finde ihn gut falls ihr
das jetzt nicht so seht ist es auch okay
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video
wieder ein kerzenkalender das war doch
mal toll g euch Kerzen Leute die gibt's
seit 5000
Jahren